James you said in a prior interview that
if someone's work is good then you will
get noticed and that there's really no
wall surrounding Hollywood that it's
perfectly possible to gain access to
talented people within the industry
through simplicity's as good manners
and good writing skills I think so
southern charm and and man no there's
really there is a difference you know
thank you please little things that
people notice sorry to cut you off I
don't know I know no reason to apologize
I think that there is no such thing as a
wall around Hollywood and I know a lot
of people would disagree with that
notion but I can tell you even from my
own experience I've met some fantastic
people through things as simple as
Twitter you know I might follow an
executive on Twitter that's at a major
studio or at a network or town agency
and I've had meetings just because they
like me on Twitter well we're a message
back and forth they might retweet what I
share they might respond to something I
say and I'll just send them a direct
message and say hi I really enjoy our
conversations can we get a coffee can I
meet with you or whatever it is and I've
met a lot of people that way I think
that goes a long way and so I think for
me it goes all the way back to when I
first started working in film the very
first thing I ever did was this frankly
terrible documentary on the Western
character actor dub Taylor not terrible
in the sense that it wasn't ambitious or
worthy project but technically none of
us had no idea what we were doing so
we're just running around with the
camera at 16 tried to figure out how to
make this thing work and one of the
things I did from my town of 123 people
was write letters and emails to talent
agencies all over Hollywood CAA William
Morris Endeavor at the time and asked
them if mister and experience could come
interview their clients and 80% of them
said no or wouldn't respond but 20% them
said yes on at age 16 17 18 myself and
the team that did that got to interview
John Mellencamp Dixie Carter David
Zucker who directed and they could go
and they're playing all those films and
all these other fascinating
people just because we asked and so for
me that was extremely formative as a
child to say that boundaries are only
put up if we don't ask to go past them
and so for me even in the digital era
it's easier that's ever been because now
you can just shoot an email make a phone
call send a message what's the worst
they're gonna do tell you know so it's
okay to respond and ask what's not okay
is to pester and there's a very big
difference between the two and that's
why I think that Twitter and Facebook
and platforms like that can be good
because if you can strike someone's
attention if you can get their attention
then there's a digital kind of
relationship form they have an idea for
your tastes than what you like and what
you don't like and then maybe perhaps
maybe there might be some type of
relationship that can come out of that
can you give examples of follow-up
versus pestering because we all think we
have the project I think it's just it's
just human nature we think that ours is
different so what is the what's the
difference between persistent polite
follow-up and pesky well one of the
things I like to do for following up
with projects or you know if I had a
meeting I pitched something and say I
haven't heard back for a while
I try not to send emails or make phone
calls on a weekly or daily basis and
I've seen people do this where they had
a meeting and they're like oh it was so
great to meet you bubble god that a week
later they haven't heard back oh hey as
I see you again and then I'm up late or
whatever it is they keep going and going
and going
in my own experience and also talking to
executives no one responds to that but
what they do respond to is they respond
to knowing what's going on with you and
what you are doing so one of the things
I like to do is every six months every
year or whatever it is say I haven't
heard from someone in a while I might
send them an email to say hey haven't
heard from you in a while I hope your
life is going well your projects are
going well I just wanted to let you know
about this thing I just made here it is
hope you have a great day very simple
very short very direct because something
that no one does respond well to in
Hollywood are five paragraphs of well
prose they want to read a one or two
sentence very efficient dictum about
what your point is because they get
hundreds of emails a day and don't have
time to read your eloquent soliloquy on
on what you've been doing and what you
need from them and I think that is the
differentiator instead of making it all
about what you want tell them about what
you're doing and engage them what can
you do for them as opposed to what they
can do for you don't make it so
transactional make it broader and keep
it brief and keep it brief very brief
you